hello and welcome to this video playing
merius one I guess engine okay let's go
for the bangko experimenting with it
stop first recording of the day that's
something that I recently looked at but
to have to admit that um forgot the
details like is snatching upon him quite
clearly and the question is this why
have a compensation I mean more than
compensation or just enough because why
definitely has something that's so
pretty much out of the question what
seemed casualty I gasp queen screen you
form an issue maybe
it is an issue if I castle Queenie for
is a problem but what do I do here and
the stuff you should better know than
trying to find out I think it was okay
up to i canno I can go night before here
maybe Quincy 593 that should work when
you father's d5 okay I don't see why it
doesn't work maybe I'm overlooking
something maybe you can just play pool
Queenie to but then I go back night a 42
c 6 that should be enough yeah I just
thought the five and I stopped my
calculation or is there something this
well okay I cannot castle that's
definitely definitely true so let's go
back and cover seven Bishop g5 ok f6 I'm
not happy about weakening the squares
but it's not it's maybe not all that
problematic
or anything else I can try age 6 just
take sticks and then the other night out
maybe avoiding f6 is nice takes takes 90
396 maybe I'm getting away with that
castles next and it's like a dream come
true no hmm so I managed to get out of
the center and keep my porn he still has
a very healthy initiative okay but
nighty night if I if I didn't know about
my knight on d4 is also quite well
placed
only night 84 I can be irritating here
to via text my power I cannot easily
advance it yeah we'll see he has to
decide on a queen position first okay
what to do here yeah this night a force
retaining Queen 85 it's not XD final
answer should be avoided
and some way to cover probably not to
cover this pawn queen d 6 I have to
speed up that's really important yeah
then once my adium cover this maybe he's
got beef or something maybe maybe but
takes G 48 good work
it's very messy let's see what he does
before takes g4 hmm
before I can also go see for but still a
G products maybe f6 against that I had
sets an idea actually go f6 removes the
night ok so that's not so relevant
anymore he played to Roxy one so if i go
rook e8 here what's the deal just attack
the night okay so go away please c4
the Knights cannot be all that brilliant
on that square what about a four-night
just attack it somehow let's go here and
the tickets 95 queen bee five the night
doesn't seem to have a good square then
okay just goes back okay I'm g-49 h4
time morning just to wonder how to make
some real headway here check this try to
move the night and play deform g-49 h4
is X i- g y you can just check ok so
that's not a problem at all moves that
so
don't have a very clear idea what to do
ok I know he doesn't threatened you
forward I can check now but I don't
don't know what it does
threatening g5 I cannot move this
annoyed unfortunately 02 how to make
some progress in this it should be
possible and now we send some pins
white resigns wow I was down to one
second that didn't really didn't quite
find a key to win I mean the position
was very good but I couldn't really find
it okay I know that this is a line I
looked at this just very recently and I
felt that black should be okay after
grabbing the pawn but I did not study
any detail so i was a bit stuck here
with what to play but should be salmon
looks very normal this also is
completely completely obvious move but
then I recognized that castle in Queenie
for doesn't work now on a night move i'm
dropping either the rook or the bishop
and the night is hanging and cannot be
protected so just castling doesn't work
yeah I came up with night before and it
felt playable to felt playable Queenie
true i canvassed Queenie towards bad i
am giving me d 5 is not a great idea
yeah here I was actually thinking the
computer wants to castle here and play
into this position which is quite
clearly interesting here then what tries
to pick that up probably with success
it's not entirely clear which should be
good for white I was actually planning
to just go back but this is probably
good compensation might see 3 and 9 25
yeah that's compensation yeah I had to
as I said solve it over the board them
engine he gives night a six well it's
quite logical unit cover c5 prepares
potential jumps here but also back and
it gives equal
okay so Queenie two was better he gifted
me that move yeah computer still wants
to cancel with this 90 to end at the
idea at the end but okay I didn't like
it this is also this feels quite okay so
yeah this one but this is stronger ok
this is stronger given by the computer
that's very logical manner now I cannot
easily cancel the engine wants to do
this and I think I would have played
that to get rid of the spinning
situation number two you why this
pattern right quite interesting position
cm so I think he played a little bit it
lacked a little bit of punch what he did
and here I'm definitely okay so rookie
one f 4 and 6 83 c 49 f 2 and now i'm
clearly better but you still have to win
it yeah take stakes 96 what the computer
likes or 96 immediately yeah i went with
this i mean here quite clearly black is
fine but it's not so easy to check get
get something going computer actually
still likes what I'm doing I'm just
keeping the position in a way trying
around a little bit down ya know aya
nights it to assert the engines choice
yeah exploiting the pins Queen takes is
this deformed like wind Sam okay that
that's a very nice solution but I think
this should work as well yeah it does it
also wins so this is also a winning
continuation was nice of him to a mini
here he was stunned a little bit after
giving up the Queen and then resigned if
he would have played some random stuff I
don't know what I would have made that I
only had two seconds left okay well
thanks for watching